[Musique]
les centraide du québec lance cette
semaine leur campagne annuelle de
collecte de fonds dix-huit mois après la
pandémie est ce que des besoins sont
toujours aussi grand est est ce que les
citoyens sont solidaires aussi solidaire
qu'au début de la crise c'est notre ca
du vendredi avec claude pinard qui est
le pdg de centraide du grand montréal et
sylvie rochette également ce soir co
fondatrice directrice générale du
regroupement partage bonsoir à vous deux
françois mathieu filion messieurs pinard
d'abord vous êtes à la tête de centraide
du grand montréal depuis juillet 1 se
fait quand même longtemps que vous
ouvrez aussi dans le milieu de la
philanthropie comment se porte la
philanthropiques et je vous demanderais
quel est l'effet que vous avez ressenti
de la crise sur la générosité des gens
mais je dois vous dire que l'an passé en
revue une année record en terme de
campagne pour centraide du grand
montréal on a retourné plus d'argent
qu'ils n'en avaient jamais retourné ça a
été le cas également dans l'ensemble des
centrales de la province du québec et
on espère que cette générosité la basse
continue c'était lui ouais et vous
madame rochât parce que les donateurs
ont répondu
présent quand les besoins de votre
organisme quand même explosé au début du
grand confinement ah oui tout à fait la
générosité de tous et rendez vous autant
au niveau des institutions que les
fondations des citoyens s'étaient
c'était remarquable ceci dit
on voit des codes de commune en baisse
on voit également aussi un tendre vers
une
une régularisation de la vie et le
tendre vers la vie normale mais la
pauvreté est encore très présentes puis
on doit se questionner sur en espérant
très fort que la générosité pas encore
au rendez vous parce que on a des
besoins qui sont encore énormes et très
très très présent est ce que vous
craignez que la générosité se tarissent
en ce moment madame richesse écoutez si
je le crains je dirais plutôt que
j'espère que non parce que comme je
voulais dit la pauvreté est très
présente le ministre disait qu'on
n'aurait pas retrouver une économie
normale avant 2027 une économie stable à
main peut avoir la peur débit la
pandémie a causé beaucoup de
problématiques au niveau de la pauvreté
de la d13 la sécurité alimentaire qui on
a vu que le réseau communautaire était
essentiel en tout temps mais on a vu
encore plus et beaucoup de jeunes ont
découvert donc on va avoir des demandes
encore pour de nombreuses années que ce
soit des gens qui on peut retrouver leur
travail qui ont vidé leur bas de laine
des gens également aussi qui ont des
problèmes de santé physique due à la
pandémie défense de l'assentiment terre
on en voit de plus en plus qui sont pas
pas retourner au travail donc la charge
de demandes d'aidé des détresses
sociales il est encore très présente et
on a besoin que les gens soient au
rendez vous pour des campagnes de
centrales parce que 113 on n'est pas
capables nous de faire notre travail on
doit être avoir la tête tranquille au
niveau du financement pour pouvoir
justement rapporte de plus en plus aux
besoins et aux citoyens de façon
adéquate en quelques mots le
regroupement partage fait quoi
le regroupement travail plutôt en
sécurité alimentaire est aussi
travail à déployer des services
d'approvisionnement durable et de
solutions durables à la sécurité
alimentaire à marielle claude pinard il
ya beaucoup de levée de fonds de
centraide qui se passe habituellement
dans les milieux de travail avec des
champions qui passe le chapeau un peu
partout et qui relance régulièrement les
collègues du télétravail pas mal depuis
un an et demi est ce que comment ça se
passait ce que ça compromet les
collectes et la collecte cette année
particulièrement en fait je vous dirais
que je voudrais que non il ya eu un
travail extraordinaire qui était fait
l'an dernier où plus de 80% des
campagnes en milieu de travail sont
passés en mode en mode en ligne et je
vous dirais également aussi car quelque
part on a trouvé une certaine efficacité
à à pouvoir accéder à participer à plus
de la smart campagne est elle mieux puis
les équipes sur qui font qu'ils font
travailler en entreprise et bien
franchement je vous dis que on compte
sur une équipe de bénévoles absolument
extraordinaire qui font le travail année
après année et il reste quand m au
niveau des milliers de travailleurs de
d'autres inquiétudes et l'inquiétude
vient du fait qu est-ce qui aura autant
d'employés et éventuellement de retour
mais qu'ils vont qui vont conserver leur
emploi suite aux différents changements
qui vont venir suite à la pandémie oui
effectivement et là c'est quoi le
message que vous en voyez monsieur
pinard là pour les entreprises qui
doivent jongler quand même avec une
situation qui reste incertaine faut se
nourrir même si on n'a pas de bonnes
nouvelles ces jours-ci là ça reste
incertain quand même oui puis une des
inquiétudes qu'on a c'est que les
entreprises vont investir largement dans
la relance et c'est parfaitement compris
nabeul l'autre inquiétude que nous avons
aussi c'est que ce qui arrivera quoi des
fonds publics vous parliez tantôt avec
la sénatrice d'une patte d'une
potentielle augmentation de la tps pour
venir un peu aider le gouvernement dans
ses revenus alors on pourrait avoir
peut-être une désaffectation et si
c'était le cas on pourrait créer encore
plus de presse de fait sur les
organismes communautaires une chose qui
est encourageante monsieur fillion c'est
que vous en avez parlé hier sondage que
nous avons effectués sur la pauvreté
environ 67% des gens ont réalisé
à peu près tout le monde peut être
touché par par des questions de liées à
la pauvreté et que que les inégalités se
sont équipés de la dernière année alors
c'est un message super important pour
nous parce qu'on considère véritablement
que la campagne de cette année est plus
importante que celle de l'an dernier
pourquoi parce qu'on voit beaucoup de
fatigue dans les organismes
communautaires et on voit beaucoup de
fatigue au niveau des directions niveau
également des bénévoles boursier du
guembri qu'il ya un an les demandes aux
personnes âgées de rester à la maison
les personnes âgées compose d'une grande
partie du bénévolat des organismes
communautaires ils sont revenus mais
quand même on veut s'assurer qu'on va
être là pour donner un appui
supplémentaire à nos organismes
communautaires qui font le travail
quotidiennement tous lit tous les jours
avec les gens dans le besoin je donnais
des chiffres qui avaient justement dans
votre étude de diers de centraide
les gens sont étonnés parce que quand on
fait des sondages il ne pense pas qu'on
il a présentement au québec huit cent
mille personnes qui vivent sous le seuil
de la pauvreté selon la mesure du panier
de consommation et un million deux cent
mille personnes qui vivent sous le seuil
de la pauvreté selon la mesure de
faibles revenus et toutes sortes de
mesures économiques madame rochette est
ce qu'on peut se permettre
collectivement de penser que la
situation est presque revenu normal et
qui a peut-être moins de personnes
vulnérables à aider que l'an dernier ah
non non non pas du tout pas du tout
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il ya vraiment des gens
qui vous qui par la pandémie sont encore
dans le réseau on a eu jusqu'à 300% de
plus de demandes par sur certains
territoires et ces gens là on peut soit
retrouver leur emploi soit retrouvé des
emplois à temps partiel qui ne peuvent
pas retourner sur le travail pour au
marché du travail par problèmes de santé
découlant de la pandémie découlant de la
santé mentale aussi donc non on n'est
pas revenu à la normale et les deux
besoins sont grands pour les prochaines
années à venir et il faut parler aussi
de ce qui se passe à l'intérieur des
organismes communautaires ou you la
fatigue aussi des gens qui travaillent
on était là sur le terrain en première
ligne dès les premières semaines pour
répondre aux besoins et si on n'avait
pas été là bas il y aurait beaucoup plus
de gens qui seraient mal pris
aujourd'hui cependant on a besoin que
les joueurs soient encore là derrière
nous pour les prochaines années pour les
prochaines les prochains mois je dirais
donc on espère sincèrement que les gens
vont être capables d'ouvrir leur
portefeuille et d'être là pour qu'on
puisse continuer à donner servi parce
que on se retrouve avec des gens qui
étaient donateurs maintenant qu'ils sont
bénéficiaires ah oui quand même monsieur
pinard oui c'est important que filion ce
que madame recettes viennent mentionner
c'est que on a vu une très forte
augmentation des logements sur l'île de
montréal ce qui fait qu'il marque
monoparentales signent un bail peut-être
à 150 200 $ de plus qu'elle ce qu'elle
peut se permettre les l'aide alimentaire
à vivre le vin au lieu du 28 et ce qu'on
veut faire la centrale est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons besoin des gens
qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui ils
engendrent la population québécoise
s'est donné l'opportunité à une femme et
un père de famille de s'occuper de ses
enfants dans la dignité notre de gagner
sa vie dans la dignité de passer de
bénéficiaires à contributeurs et c'est
pour ça qu'on fait encore un appel très
fort on a besoin de vous jeter n'est
parfait l'appel est lancé et dernier
appel je pense vous avez toujours besoin
de bénévoles en madame rochette parce
que est-ce qu'une pénurie de bénévoles
absolument une pénurie de bénévoles les
gens vous disiez tout à l'heure que les
gens les gens à la retraite retourne un
peu dans les organismes communautaires
mais encore de pénurie de bénévoles y
emmène de pénurie ou si au niveau de
l'emploi des ressources humaines et on a
besoin de gens c'est sûr et certain et
je vous dirai en finn 5 oui investir
dans la pauvreté c'est investir au
niveau de notre avenir économique mais
également aussi de notre avenir humain
en tant que société je pense que c'est
un devoir que tout le monde doit avoir
pour avoir un meilleur meilleure société
de données et ces zones économiques on
en parle monsieur pinard je vous laisse
15 secondes pour finir sans vous voulez
dire quelque chose merci de nous avoir
invités merci de parler la pauvreté
monsieur fillion puis la mission de
centraide du grand montréal à la fin de
la journée s'est assuré une lutte à la
pauvreté et l'exclusion sociale comme
moteur de développement économique et
social alors dès des grands messages et
des beaux messages qui seront sans doute
bien entendu merci à vous deux ce soir
merci merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh